MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Companies looking
to make predictions require
vast amounts of data,
complex calculations,
and rapid responses.
Join us as we talk
to LiftIgniter
about how they built the
machine learning platform
on this episode of Stack Chat.
Thanks for joining us.
Tell us a little bit
more about LiftIgniter
and how you built your platform.
VENKAT VENKATARAMAN:
Thanks for having me.
LiftIgniter is a real-time
personalization platform
powered by machine learning
models running in the cloud.
By real time, we mean
end-to-end latency
in the order of about
100 to 150 milliseconds.
And this includes the
network latency as well.
Now, this is a real
challenge both in terms
of scale and
computation because we
track a number of
signals by users
in order to provide them
with the most relevant
and personalized
recommendations.
Our world view is that
each person is unique.
And at every moment
in time, our platform
is optimized for the
most relevant results
based on all the signals we
gather up until that point.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Can you
show us the architecture
you built to keep this moving?
VENKAT VENKATARAMAN: Sure.
As an ML company that
crunches and stores
huge volumes of data,
infrastructure cost
has a large impact
on our business.
We focused on three
main factors--
pricing, latency,
and reliability,
just like anyone else.
To emphasize these, we
used three main techniques.
Auto-scaling based on
workload, lets us make sure
that we have the
flexibility to scale out
heavy workloads on demand.
And we use a combination
of auto-scale groups
either for preemptible instances
and for on demand, which
leads us to the second point,
which is the flexibility
to allow us to use
preemptive instances as
needed, and thirdly,
the option to move
stale but useful data
into cold storage, again,
for cost reduction.
When it comes to speed,
network latency usually
has a huge part to play.
But Google's network
has been pretty snappy
in our experience.
We have been able to keep
components that chatter a lot
close by within the same
region with enough redundancy.
With Google's Footprint, we're
able to create and run services
closer to the edge so that all
the customer-facing services
perform really well.
And we have also
been able to avoid
any outages that'll affect our
SLA, thanks to Google Cloud.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Can you
tell us a little bit more
about how the recommendation
system was actually built?
VENKAT VENKATARAMAN: Sure.
The diagram is actually
a simplified architecture
diagram.
We are not showing the
load balancer, and proxies,
and things like those.
But it just focuses on the main
components and the services
that we have in
our architecture.
The requests to our
cloud are either
going to hit the
front-end APIs, or what
we call as the model servers.
The model servers
are the ones which
for anything that has
got to do with user
activity and returning
recommendation results,
that's taken care of by
the model servers, where
all the magic happens.
For everything else,
like, for example,
updating or creating
new inventory items,
or making other API
calls will actually
hit our front-end services.
Now looking at the front-end
services, when an API
call comes in, a
bunch of processing
happens on those
front-end machines.
And the front-end services,
they push the data
into data storage.
We create either
files or other data,
push it into some data storage
like Google Cloud Storage.
We also have other data stores.
And GCS would actually
trigger an event
into Cloud Pub/Sub where we have
a lot of subscribers listening
on messages on those topics.
And a subscriber could pick up
those, do further processing,
and an example
shown in the diagram
is where we have an
inventory system which
does further analysis
and processing based
on what the trigger is.
The model servers are the
ones, like I said before,
which handle all of
recommendations and the user
activity tracking.
They do a lot of
processing in-house--
a lot of magic happens here,
a lot of heavy lifting happens
here--
pushes the data, once
again, into data storage.
A similar mechanism happens,
which triggers an event
into Cloud Pub/Sub.
And we have
subscribers listening
on those topics, which
pick the data from GCS,
do further processing.
And as shown in the
diagram, this data
is now pushed real
time into BigQuery
where our dashboards are fed
off of BigQuery for analytics.
The key thing here is
while we can move things
into BigQuery in real
time, BigQuery can also
get a little expensive, so we
want to keep access to BigQuery
only when we really need it.
So we have an offline
processing which takes data off
of BigQuery, does
further aggregation,
pushes it into Cloud SQL, which
acts like a caching layer.
So the dashboards would either
hit Cloud SQL our BigQuery
depending on how far
back in time they
want to go and gather data.
The box at the bottom shows
our Spark cluster, which
runs off of Cloud Dataproc.
And the Spark
cluster is basically
used for tuning our
models and retraining it
for better accuracy.
We run it on a nightly basis.
We gather all the data from GCS.
We have the models
running all over again.
And if the results of those
models with the tune parameters
are better than
what it was before,
we make the necessary changes
and push those configuration
into the cloud.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Now,
it's been a while since you
architected this originally.
If you could go back
and do it again,
what would you do differently?
VENKAT VENKATARAMAN: We started
architecting our platform
around 2013, 2014 when machine
learning was still not hot.
Big data was still
the thing of the day.
It wasn't as hard or widely
available as it is today.
If we had all the libraries and
frameworks that are available
today back then,
then some of the
build versus buy decisions
would have been different.
We also enabled
augmented intelligence
by giving our users the ability
to influence recommendations.
Sometimes they may
implement rules
that can get a bit
too restrictive
and end up returning
less results.
To help enable the
customization for these users,
we've been researching
indexing solutions
to give better results.
Part of this was
investigating something
like Elasticsearch,
which was good,
but it wasn't
performing as fast as we
needed because of a really
tight latency requirements.
We're currently
looking into other ways
to build this and keep serving
improve recommendations.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thanks so
much for sharing the details.
VENKAT VENKATARAMAN:
My pleasure.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: If you'd
like to try setting up
Pub/Sub notifications for
Google Cloud Storage yourself,
check out the walkthrough
in the description below.
Thanks for watching, and
make sure to subscribe
for more great Google
Cloud Platform content.
We'll see you next
time on Stack Chat.